Brian carries fiance James backer he is
worth four billion dollars I mean when I
can pay for one heck of a wedding right
and only are Carly still join Riya
halfway around the world backstage in
Paris this is Mariah and all her
delicious penis
how are you planning a wedding while on
a world I might dress last night if you
must know and it looks good they came
and brought it you know I don't want to
go into velop man who came and brought
who are the people that can say that I
can't say they may is a fabulous
designer house that's amazing
um so does this me more I is a
bridezilla well the big French designers
names like Bowman Chanel Givenchy and
Dior come to her yep but even the
ultimate D that has a limit she wants
some of it to kind of be more
traditional traditional is my third
wedding whatever me whatever I just mean
like obviously everybody so is eat so
we're both just like normal about it
James flew in five days before to
surprise his fiance and we found out
he's a quiet guy and prefers to hang out
in the background also traveling with
Mariah are her twins rock and row I
cannot believe they're turning five on
April 30th how are they enjoying being
on tour so far I've seen that you're
great pictures and video all over the
place that looks so much fun they love
it they're like we don't go in the plane
they want to go in the airplane they're
like if we stay somewhere too long they
don't really like it like they're
travelers they love it but I need to
keep them grounded so I'm a little bit
like you know they get when I'm like hey
cut it out they're like mommy you scared
me with your voice and I'm like sorry
I'd be something
et was front row from riah's 80-minute
parish oh and look who we found right
next to us rock and roll with their
headphones on dancing to their mamas
it's adorable this moment being twirled
around by four strong dancers as
Mariah's favorite and let's just talk
about the fashion where I gets to wear
four different styles on stage backstage
we saw this sequined bodysuit and
pantyhose on the hanger and then about
10 minutes later on Mariah then you see
those cameras well they are they're
filming her eight-part docu-series
Mariah's world and then the 46 year old
gets a short break before she resumes
her Vegas residency at Caesar's Palace
June the 7th I'm going to tweak the
performance at all yes yeah we have to
do some other things I'm very excited
yeah is the wedding going to be on your
donkey series I highly doubt we're gonna
have the whole I mean I mean some things
have to be private if he's not really
that type of like let me be the star
type person so you know I can't like
force that